for the second time in less than a week
metro police called to a deadly shooting
at a convenience store
officers do tell us these cases are not
connected here's where tonight's
shooting happened take a look it's
tropicana and mcleod madison kimbrough
joining us live with more on who police
are looking for madison
as you can see behind me police are
still assessing the situation here at
the speedy mart in the southeast part of
the valley now police say one man was
shot and killed after getting into an
argument with another customer inside
the store
an altercation turns deadly and two
suspects a man and a woman are now on
the run according to metro police this
all went down around 5 p.m tuesday
the man who police say was 48 years old
was shot after getting into an argument
with a woman that woman then left the
store and returned sometime later with a
man that black male adult had
was in possession of a handgun during
which time he saw the victim and shot
the victim
as the victim was inside the store this
is the second shooting to happen at a
convenience store in the last week the
first occurred on november 5th at the
short line express market near jones and
robindale one man was killed the suspect
javier jesus aribe is now in custody and
facing several charges including murder
with use of a deadly weapon and three
counts of attempted murder he'll be back
in court next week
metro making it very clear that these
two shootings are not related i believe
this one is completely different from
the other one you're referencing which
was a very random shooting this appeared
to not be a random shooting it was very
distinct that it was the victim that was
the intended target
and as you can see police are now taking
down the crime tape as for the suspects
in the most recent shooting they were
last seen running north on mcleod drive
no one else in the store was reported
hurt during the incident and it was
actually the clerk that called 9-1-1
reporting live madison kimbrough live
local now